I think that there's a shortage of real
men on this planet if you can't take
care of your family you got to ask
yourself how much of a man are you
we have to have a little life balance
dude how can you have life balance when
you broke spend the next four or five
years becoming an expert in your field
need motivation watch the top ten with
believe nation
what's up believe nation it seven my one
word is believe in this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from being a kid labeled with a didi to
struggling with drugs and addiction and
almost dying to becoming a sales expert
best-selling author motivational speaker
and having assets in real estate worth
over five hundred million dollars he's
Grant Cardone and here's my take on his
top ten rules a success vol 9 also if
you want to know what grant and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 254 series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
short warning video for free to help you
build your confidence the link to join
is in the description below you have to
go build self-confidence
okay let's kick it off with real number
one get strong I think that there's a
shortage of real men on this planet I
think most men are I mean frankly just
[ __ ] you know I don't know if your
audience can handle that word but I
could look man if you can't get your
money right something's wrong
if you can't take care of your family
you got to ask yourself how much of a
man are you
like for me that identifies me as a man
my ability to take care of my family I
don't just mean financially but I do
mean financially right my job as a as
head of household is to take care of the
economics of the household you know the
word economy if you look it up in the
dictionary it comes from managing the
household it had nothing to do with the
business it was about managing the
household so if you go back a thousand
years we've been managing households my
job as a man is to provide a place where
it's warm place where we can sleep place
where we're protected place where
there's food right not money right I
need to be able to take care of the
family shelter food clothing and I need
to have some fun my family wants to have
fun we want to have experiences so I
need to provide a secure environment for
them so they're not think bad things
aren't just happening and so so men need
to like bone up and like the government
can't take care of you bone up you know
this yeah bone up get strong right
strong case so get a get a backbone and
take care of your family and quit
blaming the government or making excuses
that your neighbor or the economy or
what whatever conditions the guy I've
had some terrible conditions in my life
from the age of 15 till 25 it was awful
for me ten years nobody would want to go
through the ten years that I went
through did do some people have it worse
than I did probably but I don't want to
do those two those ten years were
terrible for me is degrading as a human
being can experience drugs yeah drugs
but mostly just so many bad choices so
many bad people you know so much it's
self self deprivation and and and just a
lack of self esteem and self love for
myself because of all the bad choices so
I understand what goes on through for a
person when they're making bad choices
and and and people just need to man up
you know bone up the women need to do
the same thing by the way yeah women
they're stronger than men oh look I hate
pain any kind of pain women can handle
ten times the pain I can handle rule
number two decide to blow up my jobs to
get eight billion people to know me if
enough people know me they'll buy from
me how many believe that I'm not gonna
be sick I'm not gonna be a slave to one
person or one vertical or one niche or
one partnership I have you guys have the
whole world at your access the whole
world and by the way if you can't get
South Korea to talk about you you can't
get South Indiana or Indianapolis to
talk about you there's people in Korea
that are tied to Hawaii that are tied to
Columbia that know somebody Indiana and
it can just bang out like that and I
also believe that if I could get enough
people to know me in one market I think
that there's something that actually
happens I think if you could alpha it
you if you could get if you could push
out enough frequency about your brand
yourself your ideas to enough people
that you hit some critical mass I don't
know if any of you agree with this but I
think there's a spiritual component to
where if you can vibrate through enough
all of a sudden other people start
thinking I know that
I've said this for years if I can get
enough people a very small percentage of
the population to know me I think the
other 99% become convinced they know me
do you think that somebody needs to
reach a certain like status before but
no no no you do not need to reach
certain status you need to assume the
status now you need to have the altitude
right now to be the professional it says
hey I know about Fitness I know about
plumbing I know about trucks just take
whatever you guys are certain about and
posted of it and by the way if you're
not certain about it write an article
about what your uncertainties cost to
you
you want to figure out every possible
angle but none of that's gonna happen
until you guys make a decision to blow
up and none of the blow up shit's gonna
happen until you make a decision that
money is important because if you've got
people around you say money's not
important they know when you're gonna do
this stuff because this hurts when
nobody sees your stuff rule number three
study to multimillionaires number three
number three studied to
multimillionaires do not take heed to
this do not study a millionaire once a
person becomes a millionaire the first
thing they do unfortunately is going to
conservation to protect the million
study multi millionaire study people
that have consistently developed and
proven because the tens or 20s or 30s
are hundreds of millions of dollars that
they've accumulated that they have the
right practice the right discipline and
they're still expanding you don't need
twenty-two mentors study two people deep
that have gotten it right study two
people are so deeper than 20 people
shallow I promise you will make a
difference if you get a chance to spend
three days with anybody that's
accumulated 30 40 50 a hundred million
dollars I'll promise you it's a
game-changer so put that on your bucket
list I'm gonna spend three days with a
multi-millionaire in an environment
where I can learn from them it will be a
game-changer for you and also limit your
study to two people not twenty two
people that will create you from having
conflictive data and content and
information number four get a team
nobody's ever done it by themselves
mmm-hmm so the old the the entrepreneur
that's popular right now is the guy that
works for
home he's a solopreneur I don't know if
you have this term we have been yeah
yeah it's a complete misnomer nobody is
ever existed on this planet and done
something successful by themselves no
it's never happened so there's no
there's zero examples of anybody that's
done any I mean Jesus had had 12 had 12
guys he was rolling with right Alexander
the Great had an army Genghis Khan had
had a like you're not doing this thing
by yourself nobody does like for too
long I ran by myself
and and it took a lot of energy you know
it took a lot of energy it takes more
energy running by yourself
Ryan Seco here the captain the pilot and
and the real estate dude he always says
dude it's just more fun to run with the
team and he's right yeah you know Henry
Ford people said Henry Ford made the car
out of his garage said yeah but the
company didn't make they didn't make
through the yeah yes so Mark Zuckerberg
so you know Facebook was made out of a
dorm Facebook was made when he moved to
Silicon Valley and started a company a
Steve Jobs Steven and the other dude was
it dude yeah yeah that built Apple you
know supposedly built it out of their
garage yeah no nobody knew about Apple
until he moved the company and started
in added employees so nobody's doing
anything great by themselves rule number
five
sacrifice you guys that take days off
it's my day off
yeah entitled to a day off well why do
you think you should have wins days off
or Thursday sir or you can't work
Saturdays or Sunday Sunday you can't
work on a Sunday okay are you and you
got people around you telling you not to
work on son oh we have to have a little
life balance dude how can you have life
balance when you broke how can you have
life balance at a Holiday Inn when the
people next door keep you up all night
and ain't light balance that's not even
a vacation right the whole trip how many
been on the trip you did the budget trip
included the free breakfast
you did it on miles and you wish you
didn't even go
how many been on that trip before maybe
you don't do the trip maybe you're not
entitled to a trip this year maybe
you're not ready a trip
that's what Elena and I did for ten
years was sacrifice the sacrifice today
we'll sacrifice this week we'll
sacrifice this month we'll sacrifice
this year we'll sacrifice so one day
maybe we don't have to compromise every
week we talk about our finances what do
we do this week how much do we make
where are we going what are we spending
okay the moment I say hey no more
jackets no more bus stop it she'll stop
it so that we can one day we can one day
spend whatever we want okay there there
there is should come a time where you
guys should be able to spend whatever
you want but most people are spending
what they can't afford now a land mine
that later they can ever have any
understand how to make their money
multiply and most people don't
understand there is a sacrifice phase we
went through the sacrifice phase where
there was years of just cut off every
and we weren't saving for night you know
you're here for the rainbow that's right
y'all need to save for the rainbow you
see we didn't go on a vacation for 13
years
yeah I've been saving for this stuff I
wasn't saving for vacations I was saving
so I could bank into real estate so I
could go to sleep at night and even if I
had a bad night of sleep and had to get
up three or four times I'm like dying
I'm making money in my sleep even if I'm
not happy I'm like I'm making money in
my sleep and losing that's the goal yeah
you and your wife need to have let's
make money when we go to Turks and
Caicos when we go to st. Barts when we
go to Cali
let's go waste some money later in our
life maybe you say hey I'm gonna
sacrifice today so I don't have to
compromise in the future rule number six
become the expert I'm not 20 years old
and contracting here at Michigan OH
the biggest question he you know gained
credibility of business being young in
the industry yeah so good question I'm
glad you said new to the industry not
because you're only 20 years old you got
it you got to get you got to become
you've got to become the the expert
buddy
I don't know how to tell you this any
other way you got to become you got to
become the expert in the room you got to
know more than everybody else you got to
be like people say oh if you're in if
you're in a room and you're the smartest
guy in the room you're in the wrong room
you go in a room yeah you need to be the
smartest guy in the room you need to be
the guy in the room
this sucks the oxygen out of the room so
Elon walks walks in a room and I always
like going up to the office but doing my
best just try to build rapport no no no
done don't try to build rapport dude you
got it you got to become an expert at
your deal like if you're milking cows
you need to become the freakin god it
knows every freaking angle on an owner
on a cow's titty okay like right okay
Jeff so dude take Kate like like you're
20 years old bro spend the next four or
five years becoming an expert in your
field study it breathe it live in it
don't drink the kool-aid do backstrokes
in it rule number seven do many things I
don't do businesses that don't serve my
life so the real estate it's just what
I'm doing every day right it's the
speaking it just all fits for me so I
need a lot of action but they all work
like like my hand I move my pinky and
all the other fingers removed so if I
move this business it touches these
businesses the businesses are all
connected are interconnected that
they're a bit connected right so if I
move one we came here to do a speaking
gig okay but we stack this interview
this is part of my business right my our
online presence is dependent upon me
being willing to do this in addition we
don't go anyplace for one thing mm-hmm
so the guy that tells you focus on one
business we do why don't we have one
finger why don't I just have one finger
right hit the floor everybody boom I got
I got notice I got five fingers and I
got two hands I had I had a girlfriend
but this was before I was married she
says you want your cake and you want to
eat it too
and I said yeah well I have a cake if
you can't eat it
okay so my mom used to tell me you need
to focus on one thing at a time I'm like
Five Fingers five two hands okay so I
want my hands and all a bunch of pies I
just want to be sure I want to eat that
pie okay I want to eat that meal right
because I think a lot of people have
their hands sorry I think a lot of
people have their hands and stuff they
don't really want to eat the meal rule
number eight focus do you guys just
rubberneck your whole life you know you
ever been driving down the road there's
a record yeah and everybody's like oh my
god why is all the traffic stopped
there's only one person with a flat tire
on the side of the road right
everybody's stopping to see what the
hell happened over there you rubberneck
in your life and not getting where you
want to go okay cuz everything's a
distraction
some people call it schizophrenia like
my friend Kathleen but it's not really
schizophrenia it's a lack of focus rule
number nine make hard decisions fast
number nine make hard decisions fast
people say man you're a hard man you're
a tough dude okay look you've got to
make hard decisions fast when things get
tough they say the tough get going truth
is when things get tough the successful
make hard decisions quickly
that's why super successful people are
often misunderstood they're willing to
make hard decisions that often don't
make them look good and for which
they're later judge the truth is for you
to be financially successful you will
have to make very very difficult
decisions when you do make them fast my
mom used to say if you're walking
through hail Sun pick it up go fast and
rule number ten the last one we for a
very special bonus clip is get the right
knowledge I want you to walk away
understanding that some of you have
businesses that are just not good
businesses and if you have a business
that's no good
you can't build the Empire you want why
do I need money what don't I know about
money why are people struggling with
money you should ask yourself these
questions why are you coming up short on
money
is that what you know or what you don't
know how many of you know they're saying
knowledge is okay how many of you agree
with that how many agree knowledge is
power so look if you don't have money
and you have knowledge maybe you have
the wrong knowledge I've got a really
special bonus clip from Grant on how to
commit fully that I think you're really
gonna enjoy but before that is time for
the three-point landing questions time
to move from just watching another video
to actually taking action in your life
or your business and if you're feeling
bold leave the answer to the questions
in the comments below here we go
question number one what to multi
millionaires are you going to study
number two what are you going to be the
expert in and number three what hard
decision do you need to make today
I hate sales hated it five I was in five
sales jobs was a disaster and all of
them hate it absolutely hated you're the
master of sales I am I am I embrace the
things I why why were you bad at it why
did you hate it I didn't know well I was
bad at it because nobody teaches anybody
how to be good at sales you know so I
didn't know how to communicate to people
it didn't know how to shake her hand
didn't know how to build rapport I'm on
it honest enough that I'm not gonna lot
of people so the stuff I was being
taught to do I didn't like you know they
asked a question you asked them a
question slaw me dude you know I have
enough integrity and ethics that when
you tell me okay we're not manipulating
but don't answer their question
[Music]
that's just that that is manipulation
and that's why I think a lot of people
don't like sales because of what's been
taught from blueprints outdated you got
there you know it was thought it was
always wrong okay
it was wrong and it's why I believe
that's why salespeople have so such a
high turnover why so few people want to
be called salespeople I mean you go
through Harrods down there you can't
find a salesperson in the whole joint
you think salespeople are ostracized in
America oh dude this right here is
terrible I mean really we've had books
where seller be sold we had to change
some of the language in the book for it
to be ambushed no sir
so like the word pressure can't be in
their persistence can't be in there like
there's things you get laws you guys
actually have here that like
go to Europe it gets one step worse you
know cuz it's a whole I'm ashamed of
money and I don't want to talk you know
how to talk about that too but so the
sales blueprint you get in they give it
to you it's not working for you it
doesn't make sense for you and you're
like I got a I got to make my own well
what happened was was I was in a sales
job I got at college - I got a college
degree in accounting and because she
thought it would teach you about money
and it did yeah so so I end up in the
sales job slowly Java and so I hate it
right so I'll go to the treatment center
I'll come back out attribute Center I
threw myself into it because it's the
only thing I had
III still had so little self-esteem that
there was no way I was gonna go try to
get another job
Yeah right and I was terrified of using
drugs again so I'm like I went back the
the place where I was working they took
me back and I just threw myself into it
and it's interesting when you commit to
something little gifts just start
automatically showing up it's a
phenomenal thing so so I threw my guy
walks up he gives me it was a little
cassette day he's like hey I heard this
I thought you might like it
I listen to us oh my god there's a way
to sell stuff I didn't know there was
actually something you could do I
listened to it I called the 800 number I
said what else do you have
and the guy said we've got a program for
three thousand dollars it's 25 years ago
so it's like 10 grand so I don't have I
said I'll call you back call my mama
said I need a bar triggering first money
I ever Bart outside of college she gave
me the three grand and changed my career
[Music]
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
[Music]
if you want to learn more from Grande
check out the video we did on him on how
to become a millionaire the videos right
next to me I think I'm going to enjoy
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
while many of you may say they had a
millions enough trust me if you come up
short and your goals set them higher